[Music]
do you guys know who diplo is
yes of course yes you guys fan of his
music i love diplo i'm just a fan of
him as a person i didn't i like him but
i don't know any of his songs
me neither sorry
[Laughter]
he's very different from the other other
djs that go
oh he's more like a boom boom boom boom
right yeah
yeah so for those of you guys that don't
know diplo is a dj
in the edm world yes
for those of you that don't know
you don't know diploma he's big i've
heard the name
dippo but i couldn't have told you who
he is oh i know i know
the hippo too super big in the edm world
diplo short for diplosaurus actually his
favorite dinosaur diplosaurus really oh
[ __ ] actually i actually met diplo at a
wedding he was he was a dj at my aunt's
wedding what
who works at apple and and he she
somehow got a connect
through she works for apple music and
she got a connect
with diplo to come and dj at her wedding
that's so cool and your aunt's a fan of
diplo
i have no idea but she just had a
celebrity like we need a dj
yeah i need a celebrity dj
he hasn't even played his own music he's
just playing like
wedding music yeah it was like a lot of
bruno mars like oh
that's suck it might be refreshing to
him
but he's not even spinning it's just
like a [ __ ] playlist
true and he's getting paid for it why
don't you get diplo to do with that i
know except for just to say he's doing
it i don't know yeah you know what
the later when i he probably did i also
was really drunk so i had
no idea what happened or it wasn't
actually
it was d-i-p-p-p-p-l-o oh right right
the knock-off
blow whatever you do
all right so diplo is making he's not
making headlines he's
uh going viral for a very strange reason
oh no
so um i just said i liked him as a
person as [ __ ]
yeah i'm glad you repeated it too
i think there's nothing nothing
confirmed about this
oddness but okay so if you if you don't
know this part is that diplo has a new
roommate on his compound
yeah yeah well he has like a studio
thing and like at his house and
like prince yeah like most music artists
i would imagine that every music artist
has
a studio mansion yeah and he's
uh rented it out a certain space out to
a 19 year old tick tocker a female 19
year old
oh is it charlie no uh she goes by the
name of
no that's blue yeah you know her yeah uh
what's her name the black chick though
this is her
i don't i don't have the privacy you
have the screen on
oh what the hell oh right right right
right quinn blackwell
i do believe but he's with like
chantelle chantel
bam freeze or something isn't he is she
is she like a really famous tick talker
right now
yeah yeah she hits like the millions wow
every single tick tock is in the middle
sounds like a really good business
decision
so what's wrong with that so far all
right so
i'll play you so uh a compilation of
videos that i found
that were on what's her name quinn uh
quinlan
blackwell yeah so i'll play a
compilation video
and uh this is what's quinlan blackwell
yes boomer news i know
everyone's watching us right now like
man you can really tell their [ __ ]
age on this one
junior high the black two-pack shocker
all right here we go you guys be the
judge well you don't have to pay right
now
hey guys what's going on tour but um i
still want to give you all content of me
living with dimples so i'm just going to
show you some of our texts
if you ate my chicken salad thing i'm
gonna fight you i haven't eat [ __ ]
this is when we were getting robbed i
said call the police he said better get
your weapons ready and i was like no for
real
police i'm scared and he said they had
us on hold how did the police that was
the road
i'm living with diplo the series he
doesn't know how to tie his shoes
where's the other string
since y'all care so much about me living
with diplo just started a series called
living with different okay
so he has a peloton in my room and he
has all these profiles
right now all right so the internet is
going crazy over this
weird pairing what's weird about the
living situation it is weird
they don't wanna yeah it's like the odds
is it like a
the black and white thing they don't
like that uh there seems to be a little
bit of that i guess i don't know but
it's more of an age thing so uh quinlan
she is
19 uh or 20. that's 365 days over the
age limit
true true and then
they say they're not but people are
assuming that there's more going on
behind the scenes that they
they're letting that relationship look
like [ __ ] brother sister
yeah it looks straight homey homie it
does when you're secretly
[ __ ] a celebrity you don't make a
bunch of tick tocks with
that's correct right was wasn't he isn't
he dating that model
sean chan okay jeffries
yes yes wait how old is diplo diplo is
in his 40s
okay yeah so it's like a good 20-year
age gap
and a lot of people are confused as to
why
he this one particular girl is the
roommate
uh at his facility at his at his home
basically
um so then she released a statement on
twitter and she says
i'm an adult i'm not being groomed oh
there's a lot of people thinking she's
being grossed
out it's like especially with like the
the weinsteins and
all that [ __ ] that's happening and
epstein's and stuff uh
r kelly r kelly yep uh so a lot of
people just have a lot of
bad uh i guess like young girl older
guys yeah there's bad story lines in
their head already so when they see this
they're assuming the worst so then she's
saying uh
i'm an adult i'm not being groomed
platonic relationships exist i've been
living here for over a year i'd rather
break both my legs and be forced to walk
than pursue diplo romantically and he'd
rather choke
he's barely in la because he's so busy
diplo has given me the opportunity and
security to create
duplo and his team are my mentors in la
and they are my safety net
diplo and his team have saved my me
numerous times from the weirdos in la
my parents trust him i trust him y'all
are making me feel icky diplo is my la
dad nothing more
that's cool when you have to open a post
with i'm not being groomed it just shows
you how much the internet assumes every
[ __ ] single thing
yeah it's nuts it's mostly because she
became popular when she was a minor so
people just have
that and then they still think that
she's like a young adult
and i do believe like she was young but
she was developed and there was a bunch
of like creepy
[ __ ] going on around that with creeps
like on her profile yeah yeah
yeah it was a lot like a protective over
her type thing
but yeah they're just assuming [ __ ] yeah
they're not being a boomer man
no problem yeah thank you thank you so
much uh yeah
and on her profile too like there's a
lot of videos where
she kind of like just struts around the
house and dances
like without a whole lot of like i saw
that one no no bra
no not yeah just kind of like she's very
free with her body it's also
her house though right so she can do
whatever she wants some people are
some people some people are saying uh
here we go here's the tweet that says
what we're saying is that he's a known
creep and this arrangement is
inappropriate on
his part i hope you understand that and
realize it's not who it's not you who's
waiting crazy
he's been a known creep like he's he's
he's been convicted of [ __ ] before
yeah so another layer to this is the
fact that diplo has actually gotten
flack in the in the past for
um retweeting uh underage girls for
talking to his songs
and so a lot of people saw that as a
strange
gesture towards did they look under it
did they i don't know if i'm pretty sure
but did they look underage or whatever
they just hadn't been aware
that they were on that i didn't dig up
those videos i i don't know
i don't know that's hard to prove
anything because if you're a musician
and you have a compilation of people
dancing to your music
you're just going to be like my fans are
dancing to my neck you want people to
dance to your music and you guys are
also assuming that he's doing it himself
like he could have a team that's just
in charge of his twitter yeah yeah and
not like necessarily writing it but just
making sure that there's like engagement
that's all they got on this cat is that
he retweets some people i thought he was
i thought he got convicted as a a
pedophile or something nothing in the
legal realm
he's not a known creep a known creep to
me means that someone
actually got caught either in you know
touching like yeah like like they were
either convicted
or there's a lot of women with evidence
that's like yo
i was like 15 and this dude was trying
to [ __ ] me and this and that or whatever
that that that's a known creep yeah yeah
none of the who's the guy that did
did have those accusations chris deleon
yeah like none of that kind of stuff but
yeah these are all
assumptions uh so then thomas wesley
which is his uh
name uh diplo's name he said okay
so i rent one of my properties to uh
quinlan
and yes i use the studio that is in that
building her social media is sarcastic
and chaotic and i can see you can get a
twisted idea
but there's nothing but a friendship
between us he continues as a landlord i
don't really consider
age or race as a qualification you just
gotta pay secured
deposit and don't poke holes in the
walls or ruin my carpet
that was that's all i can't be his name
i can't i can't remember from him then
yeah that's true you'll be poking holes
yeah there's so many holes in these
monsters
holes in the carpet that's why we have
wood floors at my other place and
i try to make it beautiful so i don't
poke holes in it true
and you can't live with diplo dude
that's something i know i want to live
with diploma
but he says he doesn't have that many
friends he must be a [ __ ] dick
you think so really he's always around a
lot of people or he's just a shy rich
person
true true and people probably taking
that statement they use it like i just
don't have a whole lot of friends and
twisting that up
to make it feel even more creepy or
weird yeah you can't have friends your
own
only friend is a 19 year old then yeah
it's like damn people love this
[ __ ] the people accusing they themselves
kind of perverted and weird oh yeah you
assume
that goes directly to that yeah that
there's pedophilia going on or she's not
even under age but there's this like
sex slavery or whatever going on
grooming
gloomy yeah yes but then is there an age
limit
to grooming no i don't think you can
groom it if you're 70 21
you're being groomed by like a 30 year
old or something like or like let's say
you're 70 right
and you've been talking to this chick
that's 45. is that grooming
i think that's grooming when i was 14
i mean the whole thing about grooming is
we're getting them ready for when
they're 18 so you can do what you
want to do so that's not grooming though
rooming for it yeah
what is he waiting for yeah as soon as
you turn 26 girl like
i don't i don't get it
dad that's true i was 14 trying to groom
20 year olds it didn't work i wasn't
cute enough
but what about the reverse grooming
when you are underage and you are
predatory
girl toward people that are older than
you yeah what is that called
jail bait that's what it is
i was trying to be jail bait but i
wasn't bait enough
damn i know